hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten bild ich habe heute ein sehr
einfaches rezept für euch wir machen
nämlich einen leckeren nachtisch ist
gibt rhabarber krampe und zwar ist es
ein nachtisch aus dem backofen
ich werde gleich rhabarber klein
schneiden und das kommt den auflaufform
rein und darüber kommen richtig schöne
knusprige streusel aus haferflocken sind
mail
und das ist schon bisher das karma warm
und kalt essen
ich mag es ganz gern warm mit einer
kugel eis noch mit dazu und es ist
wirklich ein ziemlich schnell das rezept
deswegen zeigen wir euch einfach gleich
die zutaten also für das crm berater für
die streusel brauchen wir 100 km/h
flocken ich habe jetzt der kernige und
zarte gemisch also 50 50 dann brauche
ich 100 gramm mehl 125 gramm butter 150
gramm zucker da habe ich auch schon ein
teelöffel zimt mir dazu eine prise salz
und etwas sonne extrakt und für die
füllung 600 gramm rhabarber könnte auch
mit anderen obst mischen oder anderes
obst benutzen und dann zwei esslöffel
stärke 2 esslöffel orangensaft und so
etwa zwei esslöffel zucker
das war's auch schon und ich werde jetzt
erstmal den rabatt scheel
da könnte es zum beispiel auch äpfel
dazu nehmen birnen erdbeeren irgendwie
anderes obst das euch dazu schmeckt aber
ich mag aber halt ganz gerne und nutzt
eben auch dieser sommer aus
nachdem ich den rhabarber gestellt habe
werde ich ihn einfach nur kurz klein
schneiden
dann gebe ich den rhabarber in eine
glasschüssel denn ich muss den mädels
vor noch ein bisserl marinieren wuchs
das war beim abflug termin liegt nämlich
gerne ein bisserl apfel mit dazu da
kommt jetzt noch der orangensaft mit
reimen
das sorgt auch für mittel geschmack
wissen säure dann der zimt zucker und
stärke damit die feuchtigkeit später die
aus dem rhabarber austritt auch gleich
wieder gebunden wird
das muss jetzt noch gut verrührt werden
und dann kann man das kreuz stehe lasse
und ich nehme es noch hier diesen apfel
und gibt ihn auch noch mit rein weil ich
glaube ich hatte nur fünf nur ich hatte
100 gramm zu wenig rhabarber und
deswegen ab
es geht hier auch mit rein
jetzt lasse ich das hier einfach kurz
stehen und kann er schon mal eine
auflaufform vorbereiten dann nehme ich
jetzt noch eine steinbank form und
fettet die vorher mit etwas butter damit
auch später nichts dran kleben bleibt
könnte auch eine glasform zum beispiel
nehmen einfach vorher bisschen fetten
und jetzt kann ich hier auch schon die
rabatte masse einfüllen und die kann er
auch da stehen so thiel weiter ziehen
die fäden hier übrigens sind vom rabatt
sind keine haare auch wenn es so
aussieht
der aber hat halt immer diese fäden dran
nehme ich mir einfach diese schüssel da
brauchen wir jetzt auch keine frische
und macht da die krümme drin also da
kommt auch einfach alles zusammen rein
aber flachen und mehl dann der zucker
mit dem zimt etwas vanille extrakt etwas
salz und die butter die gebe ich jetzt
in kleinen stückchen mit dazu damit ich
das gleich gut verrühren kann die ich
auch schon so mittel weich als dies
nicht mehr ganz kalt
und dann verliere ich das kurz mit dem
löffel und wenn es dann nicht mehr geht
muss er die hände nehmen
man kann auch handrührgerät nehmen mit
knethaken arbeitet sich so ein rezept
auch mal nicht klappt eigentlich
maschine ist geht alles mit der hand und
am arm und an die schmutzig und kneten
es kurzerhand als im prinzip ist auch
kein krieg sondern es werden hier nur
streusel muss einfach die butter so
bisschen mit dem recht vermengt werden
und krümelig gemacht werden
jetzt gebe ich die krümel hier über den
rabatt drüber und dann kommt das ganze
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 180
grad für ungefähr 30 minuten
wenn ich unten der rhabarber und der
april die sinne schön weit und die
krümel sind schön kross
also schön gebacken und frauen und da wo
wir es gleich aus
und ich glaube zubereitungszeit war
bisher einfach 15 minuten maximal geht
recht flott
mein rabatt krempel ist fertig ich habe
es fünf minuten abkühlen lassen als 40
noch schön warm aber die flüssigkeit der
zähler gesammelt und ich richte das
jetzt an
also man sieht und hört glaube ich dass
das da oben jetzt ziemlich schön
knusprig ist und hebt es einfach mit zum
löffel raus und schmeckt gleich echt
himmlisch zu dem kalten eis
noch ne kugel himbeer ein verwirrter
klasse was auch wurde zu passen würde
wäre einfach schlagsahne wobei wenn es
dann zu warm ist und spielt die
schlagsahne zu schnell
jetzt gebe ich noch ein bisschen
zwischen schnee oben drauf liza extra
feiner puderzucker der netze vor
schmilzt und fertig ist mein bisher die
zeit noch ein bisschen grün und dann hat
man hübsches bisher und es springt echt
sein lecker und ich probiere das jetzt
noch nicht weil das ist mir noch ein
bisschen zu heiß ich möchte erstmal foto
für instagram und facebook machen und
ihr das rezept gerne nachlesen auf
sallys blog.de und ja vielleicht wollte
einfach das obst austauschen bzw den
rhabarber gemüse und mir einfach ein
foto schicken auf facebook oder
instagram und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder
bis bald